dad do you have anything to say to people that stole your nectarines
okay I forgive you
okay that's it
what can I do oh wait
that's sweet
he wanted to show you guys
this is what the nectarines looked like
do you see how full that was
he was so proud
look at that they stole all of that
all of that and more and more it’s a big tree
yeah sucks
those pictures were from July 28th
and today is what last year
and today is probably the 27th (today is in fact the 28th,,,)
oh that's so sad
he was so proud
whoever stole my dad's nectarines
you better watch out (it’s okay) you better watch out
it's not okay
no it's not okay
we forgive them it’s okay, maybe they are hungry